AINSLEY: THE FDA IS EXPECTED TO
AUTHORIZE PFIZER’S COVID-19
VACCINE FOR KIDS 12 TO 15 THIS
WEEK THIS AFTER A MARCH CLINICAL
TRIAL PFIZER’S VACCINE
100 PERCENT EFFICACY FOR
TEENAGERS.
WHAT DO PARENTS NEED TO KNOW
BEFORE VACCINATING THEIR
CHILDREN.
AUTHOR OF THE BRAND NEW BOOK
PANIC ATTACK DR. NICOLE SAPHIER.
HEY, DR. SAPHIER.
>> GOOD MORNING, AINSLEY.
>> WHAT DO PARENTS NEED TO KNOW?
SHOULD WE GET OUR KIDS BETWEEN
THOSE AGES VACCINATED.
>> AINSLEY, JUST LIKE ANY
VACCINATION AT THAT AGE YOU WANT
TO HAVE THE CONVERSATION WITH
THE PEDIATRICIAN.
THERE ARE RISKS AND BENEFITS TO
EVERYTHING.
12 TO 15-YEAR-OLDS HAVE VERY
SIMILAR BIOLOGIES TO YOUNG AGULS
ADULTS.
THEY ARE DEMONSTRATING SOME
GETTING THAT LONG COVID.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU HAVE A HIGH
RISK CHILD MAY BE OVERWEIGHT,
HAVING ASTHMA.
DEFINITELY HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH YOUR
PEDIATRICIAN.
I DON’T THINK THIS PUSH IS GOING
TO GET US TO THAT HERD IMMUNITY
THAT EVERYONE IS CRYING FOR IN
THE MEDIA.
WE ARE MUCH CLOSER TO HERD
IMMUNITY AND DON’T NEED TO
EXTEND THE VACCINATION TO
CHILDREN GOAT TO US HERD
IMMUNITY.
I DO THINK SOME CHILDREN ARE
SEVERELY AFFECTED BY THIS VIRUS.
SO IT IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE A
SAFE AND EFFICACIOUS VACCINE
AVAILABLE FOR THEM.
AINSLEY: GOOD DEAL.
YOU WROTE AN OP-ED, IT’S
CALLED -- TITLED BIDEN VS. BIG
PHARMA HERE IS WHY WAIVING
PATENT RIGHTS ON COVID-19
VACCINES IS A BIG MISTAKE.
EXPLAIN THAT.
>> SO, AINSLEY, YOU KNOW,
PRESIDENT BIDEN DURING HIS
CAMPAIGN TRAIL SAID IF THERE WAS
A SUCCESSFUL COVID VACCINE HE
WOULD GIVE AWAY THE PATENT SO
OTHER COUNTRIES BENEFIT FROM IT.
THIS GETS A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT.
THE REASON U.S. IS GLOBAL LEADER
IN PHARMACEUTICAL IS WE HAVE
SUCH STRONG MANY RIGHTS.
IF YOU GIVE AWAY WHAT WILL MAKE
THOSE PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES
WANT TO INNOVATE THIS.  IS
VIRTUE SIGNALING THIS.  DOES HE
HAVE LITTLE TO HELP NATIONS IN
NEED RIGHT NOW.
THE GOOD NEWS IS PHARMACEUTICAL
GIANTS HAVE ALREADY PLEDGED
BILLIONS OF DOSES IN ADDITION TO
WHAT THE UNITED STATES AND OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE PLEDGING.
BILLIONS OF DOSES TO THESE
COUNTRIES.
REALLY WHY SAYING THAT THEY
SUPPORT GIVING AWAY THE
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY RIGHTS,
AGAIN, VIRTUE SIGNALING DOESN’T
DO ANYTHING TANGIBLE TO HELP
THESE STRUGGLING COUNTRIES AND
IT SETS A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT BY
CHIPPING AWAY AT THESE PROPERTY
RIGHTS THAT ARE SO CRUCIAL TO
OUR INNOVATION.
IF YOU START DOING THAT NOW,
WHERE WILL THE GOVERNMENT STOP?
WILL THEY DO AWAY WITH THE
PRIVATE ENTITIES ALL TOGETHER?
THAT’S WHAT I GET CONCERNED
ABOUT.
AINSLEY: YOU MAKE SOME GREAT
POINTS IN THIS ARTICLE.
YOU CONGRATULATE OPERATION WARP
SPEED AND YOU TALK ABOUT THE
EFFORTS THAT WE HAVE DONE HERE
IN THE U.S. TO HAVE SUCH A
SURPLUS OF THESE VACCINES AND
HOW WE ARE HELPING OTHER
COUNTRIES LIKE INDIA.
IT’S A GOOD REELED.